It's that moment of getting people to
see everyone involved as human, right?
We're not there yet. Still the ways
people are talking about addiction are,
oh,
repellent, right? This is the thing of
people as being weak. I think of people's,
uh, having poor willpower, poor character,
and that's why they're addicted.
They're most people. I would, I
would say it's safe to venture,
aren't really fully
aware of what the causes,
what the underlying causes of people
becoming addicted to drugs in the first
place are. And what, what leads people
this great sense of despair. I mean,
it's really about reengineering our
entire culture. I mean, re-engineering,
not just the way we treat addiction,
but the way we treat human beings
where we treat poor neighborhoods.
I mean there's,
there's so much that needs to be done
that's never dressed totally right.
And
there's one part of this,
this a funny really when they surprises
me in this debate I have found is
actually easier in the u s to make the
case for compassion for people with
addiction problems than to make the case
for liberty for drug users who are not
addicted. Right? So, like we
were saying, even the main
drug, your body in the world,
the UN ODC,
you're an office of drug control admits
90% of all currently banned drug uses.
What's called non problematic,
right? Our friend,
Professor Carl Hart is the head of
Psychology at Columbia University in an
extraordinary human being has done
really important work explaining this to
people, even with what we think of
as the devil drugs like heroin crack.
The vast majority of people who use
heroin and crack do not become addicted.
Right. Which I found really chat when Carl
first explained that to me. I was like,
what's this guy talking about?
And then they looked at the scientific
evidence that there is very clear
evidence. Right? Um, the, the actually,
the ratio of people who use any drug who
become addicted is pretty consistently
10 to 20%. Right? Slightly
higher for things like heroin,
but it's pretty consistently in that zone.
Right?
Which is not to say that
there aren't other hoe. Heroin
depresses your breathing.
It can cause death that way. There other
harms, but we're talking about addiction.
Right? Um, so
it's interesting. There's so much. I
think we need to explain to people.
One person here in la who really helped
me to understand this and the reset for
the, because guy called Professor
Ronald k Siegel, you should,
you should totally have in your
shows is a very interesting guy.
So he was an advisor to four
American presidents. He was, uh,
wh advisor to World Health Organization.
Really serious scientist,
but he had a sideline for 30 years. We
investigated animals using drugs, right?
And he's basically shown loads of
species love getting intoxicated for the
pleasure of it, right? Sure. Elephants,
elephants like this amazing example of
I've in Golub elephants who broke into an
alcohol store, got really drunk and
just fucked up the whole village. Right?
There's a bit of a great example.
You gave what you give,
if you give hashed to mice, what they
do is they'll, they get really horny.
They try to male, nice.
We'll try to mount women,
but then they basically can't get it up.
So they just spend hours looking their
own balls and they're going to cock, uh,
Saturday loads of examples.
It's a pretty guy. Pressy. Got,
I remember he told me at one point that
he'd spent three years investigating,
um,
grasshoppers in cannabis fields who just
naturally live in cannabis fields to
figure out when they eat the cannabis,
do they jump higher or lower? And I said,
I write and at the end of your
three years, what did you discover?
And he said they'd turns out they just
dumped the same height as everyone all
the other girls offers.
So it's not really,
that wasn't a great use of your three
years of life. But he also got the,
had an interesting time
when he was in Hawaii,
he was investigating Mangu where the
mongoose is like hallucinogen psychedelics
and he, so he's like spying
on these mongooses with,
with we've been oculus and it gets caught
and it gets caught by a loaded drug
traffickers and they're like, who the
fuck are you? And he's like, don't worry,
I'm just investigating whether
Mongoose is like psychedelics.
Like that is the worst fucking cupboard
story we've ever had that held them
hostage for like two days.
But he showed us something I think is
really important and there's loads of
other evidence sport, which is, um,
it is absolutely a Nate to other species,
especially to humans.
The desire to get intoxicated,
right.
There has never been a human society
anywhere in the world where people didn't
seek out and toxicants
and enjoy using them.
The only society where there are no
naturally occurring in toxicants was the
anyway,
the what we used to be called the Eskimos
and the architect and they used to
just starve themselves to get a fucked
up head state because that's how deep it
is in human beings. If there
is nothing in there. Yeah.
If you starve yourself long enough,
you get a kind of fucked up
head state basically. How far,
how long are you going to go for? I don't
know. I looked into the details of it,
but he writes about that. Um,
but, but so it's fasting. Yeah.
Fast and courses and all to Ted State. But
that, I've never done it, but that, this,
this, this intoxication
imposters is deepen human
beings. As the sexual impasse,
you even see it in small children.
You know, when a little kid,
everyone will remember this memory of
when you're a little kid and you realize
you can spin round and round and round
even though you know it'll make you sick,
you'd do it cause you
get an altered headspace.
That is one of the first expressions of
the kind of intoxication impulse. Um,
or a really nice example
is for 2000 years, uh,
40 miles outside of Athens in
ancient Greece, they used to be, um,
once a year people
would meet at something,
a place called the temple of Hallucis
and it was basically burning man.
They would all use a psychedelic together.
We now know what that like Docker's yeah,
it was a kind of,
there's lots of different theories
but they think it was a kind of fungus
basically. Um, I remember the name
of it, but there's been research,
Liz and Simon or something. Is that, I
don't know, I want to say it wrong. I,
there was some kind of stuff I kind of
psychedelic mushrooms and like people
like Plato and Eris. Sometimes people
say no drugs or William Bennett,
the former drugs are saying drugs are
an attack on the foundations of Western
civilization. And you're like, no.
At the actual foundations
of Western civilization,
the people your holding up as the icons,
like Plato and Aristotle were literally
getting fucked up in exactly the way you
say is an attack on them. Right?
It's this deep misunderstanding.
So this is a natural human impulse.
We are never going to get rid of it.
We want to get rid of it.
It gives people a lot of joy and pleasure.
And yet the Oscar Wilde said once,
I'm going to get the quote slightly wrong,
you said it better than this,
but you said,
puritanism is the deepening fear that
someone somewhere is enjoying themselves.
And there's this puritanical
hatred of, of drug use, right? Um,
now some of that is understandable
fears, Matt genuine harms. Uh,
and that's a different thing.
But a lot of it is just very deep.
Puritanism and yeah.